an AI robot singer has taken the World
by storm this is a person is a character
created by
AI who then wrote a song you know the
computer wrote a song and then the
computer sang the song and the computer
talked about the song here she is Hello
World my name is Anna Indiana and I'm so
excited to share my music with you
here's my first song betrayed by this
town has an AI singer songwriter
everything from the key Tempo chord
progression Melody notes Rhythm lyrics
and my image and singing is
autogenerated using AI I hope you like
it my favorite Cafe sipping my tea it's
Saturday thinking about all he's done to
everyone this town is full of Broken
Dreams shattered hopes and Silent
screams somebody please
help
me the trade by this
town let's take it all down we all just
destined to
fall I've lost it
all everyone's freaking
out the the Libs you know the libs
anytime there's anything new they say oh
this is so exciting oh I love this new
thing even if it'll destroy civilization
that's great and the conservatives you
know what the conservatives is going to
destroy the world the West has fallen
everything's gone to pot
okay for
starters I can't
wait I you're looking at this now if
you're watching this you're going to say
well the graphics aren't perfect the
mouth movements aren't quite right she
still looks kind of like a little bit
like a cartoon yeah that's true but
don't worry 6 months from now now this
thing is going to be perfect think about
this when the AI Imaging tools came out
was it 6 months ago a year ago at most
they couldn't do hands they couldn't
figure out how many fingers were on our
hands and now all of a sudden they can
do this so the the AI is improving at a
shockingly fast rate so they'll fix all
that stuff soon and then for me I think
look I spent a lot of my time I read the
news then I I interpret the news I think
okay what does this what does this new
story really mean and then I reference
you know some ancient philosophy maybe
or some some medieval historical event
and I draw parallel and then I I say
okay this is how I should think about
this new story and then I write it down
in a script that I have to send to Mr
Davies and Professor Jacob and producer
Danny and then we pull clips and then I
have to send then they pull all the
clips and then I come in here and I sit
here every morning for like an hour and
I do it you know and I and I I I say
what I think about it and I gesticulate
and I I uh have different intonation and
and I change my Cadence and I'm not
gonna have to do any of that I'm not
gonna have to do any of that because a
computer robot clone is going to do all
of that for me and then I can move on to
my true passion which is selling quality
cigars at competitive prices okay that
is great I can't I look forward to
that that'll be wonderful but I my guess
my only fear is this
that's the best case
scenario I would still probably keep
doing my show you know I still think I
can out Fox the computer probably at
least for a little bit longer but like
the libs the lib news presenters who
just read this the talking points that
they get in their emails the MSNBC
people the CNN people who you you can
play all their shows back toback they
all say the exact same thing in the
exact same wording it's AI should take
their jobs that's just creating
efficiency in the
market my Fe here here's where I'll flip
to the conservative side and talk about
how the West has fallen is the primary
application for this stuff is not going
to be music it's not going to be
political news shows and commentary and
lectures and it's not going to be any of
that you know what it's going to be the
primary application for this technology
is going to be three words weird sex
stuff we all know
it the moment that they perfect this
thing and the moment that they perfect
the sex robots and you know that's
coming the human race is going to cease
to exist because a ton of it's not even
it's going to be weirdos by definition
but it's going to be a lot of people who
otherwise would not have become weirdos
but they're going to be lured in by this
they're going to they're going to use
this new technology so differently from
the way that people are using
pornography now that it's going to be
similar to the distinction between a
Playboy in the 1970s and internet porn
graphy of the last 20 years it's going
to be so tempting because it's the thing
is going to read your mind it's going to
construct an an image of a person that's
exactly to whatever preferences you have
and it's going to construct the language
model and all the other stuff and then
they're going to have sex robots and
then no one's going to get married
anymore and no one's going to have kids
and we're all going to go extinct and
that's unfortunate it's too bad but
speaking of babies and the future of
humanity we have a little bit of good
news here which is that 30
2,000 more babies were born each year
for the last couple years thanks to the
do's decision thanks to the overruling
of roie Wade and the subsequent abortion
bans in various
States 32,000 more babies per year this
is because of the state abortion bands
according to the Institute of labor
economics an average of 2.3% more babies
were born in states with abortion banss
compared to states without abortion
banss uh the group that saw the largest
increase in births were women in their
20s black women and Hispanic women so
that's a funny little line you know if
if the libs complain about this you you
can point out oh you're complaining that
more black babies are being born you
don't want all those black you want to
get rid of those black babies and you
want to kill them because you don't want
them to be walking around right because
you don't like the black people and then
they'll you know it probably won't work
it's similar to the Democrats or the
real racists line they they kind of just
Sher it off but it's a a funny line in
any case there's a downside here the
downside is the number of abortions has
remained about the same the number of
abortions is actually up slightly
According to some measures and that's
because of of one new clinics opening
new abortion clinics you know
infanticide factories in the the
pro-abortion states it's also because of
the shift in technology most abortions
now are done with abortion pills so that
increase probably would have happened
anyway probably at a higher rate um so
we got to we got to deal with the
abortion pills issue but what does this
tell us tells us two things my buddy one
of the great Twitter accounts udonia
pointed out that what this shows you is
that people were using abortion as
contraception because with an abortion B
you'd expect that number of new babies
born to be much much higher but what the
studies have concluded is that some
people who otherwise would have become
pregnant and then had abortions in
states where abortions were illegal they
just used other contraceptive methods to
prevent them getting pregnant in the
first place so even though we were told
for years that under no circumstances
are people using abortion as
contraception that obviously they were
doing that and in fact we I think we all
know people who have done that uh but
furthermore what this tells you and this
is much more important is the law is a
teacher politics is Downstream of
culture sure that's true there's there's
a lot of Truth to that it is at least as
true to say that culture is Downstream
of politics and the law is a teacher and
when you change the laws that creates
incentives and disincentives and creates
uh new kinds of behavior and that's not
just an abstract academic concept there
are 32,000 human beings people born
every year so two years now we're
talking 64,000 human beings so far who
one day will look up and be able to say
I am alive today because of the courage
of five justices on the Supreme
Court to overrule roie Wade beautiful
thing beautiful thing man what a great
clip that was now hey hold up hold up
ring that Bell subscribe to the Michael
NS YouTube channel we'll see you next
time